[Music]
we are talking to ellen in chicago and
before the break
ellen i'm going to recap this let me
know if i'm right or not
your mother has been struggling with her
health and recently was diagnosed with
dementia and she is currently
um staying with you guys is that correct
she's actually staying with my sister
stay with your sister okay
and your mother-in-law moved in and
she was
uh
she came up for a visit oh okay for a
visit okay and for the for the
convenience of not spending for a hotel
we just had her stay at my mom's condo
oh
she was um
in a recovery center from uh her um from
her
gotcha yeah because she had developed
sentences
yep okay so
your mother-in-law began asking hey
she's not gonna use this stuff could i
have some of your mom's stuff
and
in a really insensitive way in a really
insensitive time that hurt you
and if you not spoken to your
mother-in-law since you all have just
stayed apart from one another
yeah i've been very short with her on
the phone okay very short tell me about
how this hurts you
this has affected you in a way beyond
just a
well you're an idiot this is effect this
is hurt you tell me about that
because my mom's not dead yeah and just
what she was asking for were things that
were very important to my mom yeah
does she know that she hurt you
my mother your mother-in-law
yeah i think so because
for a while um
my husband and i had
gone outside to talk and i just
cried
a lot
and when it came back in she said
you know
if you want me to i'll leave early
and of course she said from the kids i
said no i mean you know they want to see
you
how much of this hurt
is
related to the incense insensitivity of
your mother-in-law and how much of this
hurt is just the
weight
that your mom's hurting and she is
coming up on the end stages of a
remarkable life
well um just to kind of keep things a
little short i had mentioned um
okay
um i had mentioned to um the lady who
took the call that we had
argued over um
something and she had actually sent me
to a box of
of the item that really
it's not gonna make sense i'm just
trying not to gross out anybody but um
i just she had done something i felt for
spice um but how much is the pain versus
um
well ironically my mother-in-law um lost
her mom to alzheimer's as well yeah
so i
i
sounds like
i get that
yeah it's a lot that that's exactly
right so here's here's here's the we
kind of whittle it down
you get to decide
in partnership with your husband what
the holidays look like
and if you are
in a place in your heart in your mind
where your mother-in-law hurt you so
deeply you don't want her around
then you get to choose that all of us
get to choose that and that choice that
boundary comes with consequences
it comes with kids that don't get to
hang out with their grandmother and it
may be worth it
or it may be kids i'm not going to be a
part of it this year me and your father
are going to go do something else so be
it
all boundary boundaries are never clean
there's always some mess to them and
people run up against those boundaries
to see if they hold
what i would love to see you do
if at all possible is to sit down with
your mother-in-law and say this request
hurt me
and maybe you didn't mean to but i want
you to know that it did and i'm not
ready to start giving away my mom's
thing she's still alive
and from this point forward i don't want
to talk about my mom's stuff
when that day comes then that day will
come but we're not there yet
and that's you taking ownership of the
situation and getting in front of it
getting on top of it and not letting it
continue to drown you does that make
sense george yeah
so
take ownership of that phone call that
phone call may be hard or you can meet
in person
maybe you have to write out what you're
going to say i've done that several
times where i know i'm going to be
emotional about a conversation and i
write down what i want to say that way i
don't get my words don't get all jumbled
up i don't lose perspective and i say
what i need to say in a respectful way
in a dignified way and then let her
respond and my guess is she didn't try
to hurt you my guess is that
she probably was being insensitive but
she had no idea she's going to cause
this this kind of pain right yeah and
holidays are messy let's all remember
when it comes to holidays man we get we
get to make a choice right we've talked
about this john on the entree leadership
podcast coming up on in a fine print
episode on the holidays and spending
families boundaries there can be so much
that bubbles up yep especially around
this time which this just happened to be
some some poor timing here as we head
into the holidays but bitterness
resentment but you get to choose your
response to it and ellen mike
my guess is
this may be the first
thanksgiving christmas without mom this
may be the first thanksgiving and
christmas
where the reality of dementia and
alzheimer's is setting in on the family
it's so hard ah it's such so hard
and then it gets it's easy to cast some
of that pain and some of that resentment
onto somebody who says the wrong thing
at the wrong time right so again do your
best to unbraid what's hurt what's real
what's it's all real but what what's
where is the hurt lie
and then be direct about addressing who
hurt you and then let's all move on
let's heal or let's make a boundary and
let's move on from there right
but i want you to take ownership of this
ellen and of all the different facets of
this thing and i know you can do it i
know you're hurting but i know you can
do it